[Música]
y hoy en directo vamos a washington
conectamos con nuestro periodista
cristóbal vázquez porque el presidente
de estadounidense joe biden y su
homólogo mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador hablaron telefónicamente el tema
central fue cómo controlar la migración
en medio de una atención pues la casa
blanca quiere acabar una orden que
permite la expulsión de migrantes para
evitar la propagación de kobe 19 y
méxico está preocupado por que esto
pueda incrementar el paso fronterizo
cristóbal bienvenido cuéntenos que
pactaron los presidentes sobre la
migración y cuáles son las diferencias
que tienen sobre el llamado título 42
hablaron hablaron durante cerca de una
hora de 52 minutos concretamente duró
esta llamada concretamente no pactaron
nada sin embargo el objetivo de la
llamada lo confirmaron varios oficiales
después de esta fue seguir trabajando
juntos en forma económica política y
social para tener una respuesta conjunta
la respuesta conjunta es lo que quieren
estos dos mandatarios de cara a lo que
se vendría después de que el gobierno de
dubai del levante precisamente la medida
del título 42 el levantamiento de esta
medida se quedaría el 23 de mayo esto es
importante tener en cuenta el
levantamiento de esta medida porque está
medido estero versión agua habilitaba la
patrulla fronteriza en la frontera entre
méxico y eeuu a expulsar a cualquier
inmigrante que haya entrado a eeuu con
el pretexto de salud pública de cara al
hobbit 19 y con el levantamiento
entonces lo que está empezando a pasar
es que ya muchos migrantes de varios
países de centroamérica de latinoamérica
incluso ucranianos en la frontera están
empezando a llegar y a llenar la
frontera
eeuu y precisamente en marzo fue el mes
donde más migrantes se han detenido en
eeuu en las últimas dos décadas así que
hay mucha preocupación no solamente en
eeuu sino precisamente en mexico que
oficiales ya les habían oficiales
mexicanos ya habían compartido esa
preocupación de eeuu diciéndoles que si
en caso de que se levantara esta medida
las olas de migrantes que llegaron a
méxico tratando de pasar a eeuu iban a
llegar a cifras récord y estas llamadas
se programó en parte por la cumbre de
las américas que hablaron los
presidentes al respecto y cuenteros y el
canciller mexicano va a ir a washington
si va a venir a washington viajará el
día lunes de la próxima semana el tema
obviamente será el tema migratorio que
fue lo que la jefe de prensa de la casa
blanca dijo que los dos mandatarios
habían hablado en casi la totalidad de
la llamada el tema migratorio y el tema
de la cumbre de las américas eran los
ángeles la cumbre de las américas entre
el 6 y el 10 de junio precisamente días
después de que se levante eventualmente
esta medida el título 42 si es que
precisamente un juez federal pues que ya
la frenó pues no es obstruido en este
interés de frenar esta medida del título
42 el tema de ucrania se trató también
oficiales estadounidenses también
dijeron que se había tratado este tema y
le preocupa a eeuu que aunque habló haya
condenado el ataque de rusia a ucrania
no ha impuesto sanciones contra rusia y
eso ha creado ciertas diferencias además
de todos los temas migratorios entre
eeuu y méxico
gracias cristóbal por toda esta
información